[Music]
forty-eight seconds for two logos to
tell you that Disney did this boom
accept your apology the director said
let's have Raph eat a giant cherry that
looks like an apple it'll make him look
like even more of an asshole let's just
distill this movie's myth about tamper
okay that guy sold alcoholic drinks to
Cowboys athletes punk rockers and aliens
the idea that he sells root beer to
these videogame characters is a lie this
is true then the adult videogame
characters in this world are depressed
as hell they can't get the good stuff
we're barely two minutes in and this
movie has a burping contest
hey Disney the kids who watch this six
years ago already thought planking was
tired
Tron has a virus which woman tell me how
that works with an arcade machine and
furthermore if these two movies have
taught me anything the arcade owner
disposes of the machines as soon as it
didn't goes wrong with him so why is he
keeping Tron plugged in Oh in the
service of one stupid joke movie yada
yada is the entire line of logic that
would explain how vanellope and Ralf got
out of the Tron game like this appears
to be the same night so what happened
did Felix come out and let them out for
27 years I was in 2001 a friend we
discussed the weirdness of different
generations of video games with
different advances in code easily moving
in and out of every game they want
because that's weird yeah also does
nobody accept vanellope and Ralf wander
from game to game in this arcade you
don't see anybody else in other games
unless it's a tapper
character humorously misappropriates
another sport when talking about playing
another sport cliche this is what I used
to tell my college roommate whenever I
thought there was a possibility of
coitus in my dorm room that night Lizzie
wife well it's either wiffle ball or an
arranged marriage game
how would Ralf have any clue about
arranged marriages I know I know it's a
joke but it's a stupid joke given the
context of the character the internet
which is an online community where human
beings go to shop so I'm explaining ya
the glitch
which stands there are glitched fans in
this universe now oh this is presented
as vanellope kicking everyone's ass in
this game on a consistent basis but if
the player who was controlling her sucks
what happens then she's super popular so
I assume she's very rarely an NPC that
could dominate on her own and yeah she
later takes the detour on her own but
apparently that's the first time it's
ever happened cool but isn't he supposed
to be inside his game right now and the
end of the last movie told us how
popular it is now ever since Qbert
characters got inside it funny how the
Toy Story characters managed to live
under one basic rule about not revealing
themselves to humans and video game
characters have none vanellope
apparently likes the idea of a new track
more than winning and she completely
removes control of her character from
the young people playing her game maybe
the point is that they never had control
but what if someone simply decided to
stop play what they see vanellope
continue hauling ass on the track and
winning no no no how are they not seeing
where I'll come into this picture on the
screen here Penelope was the only
viewable character during the race so
they should all be clearly visible right
Mary's camera you know I take my duty as
your hero very seriously Duty part 2d
how much that's more than this game
makes in a year maybe you should put
some Qbert characters into it we found
some good homes for so many of our chums
from sugar rush by the way what did
happen to those Qbert characters from
the last movie they are suspiciously not
here anymore
come along condiment that's racist why
does your lame TV only have one channel
other TVs and sugar rush the plate cable
or some it's a miracle this world has a
TV or other videogame characters that
act and chose ye oh boy oh boy this goes
on for a frustrating amount of time this
is an important mission I won't cover
for you yeah but a central character
will still be missing from the game
right wasn't this the main problem with
the last movie apparently with currency
that translates between very different
games and is never explained shots okay
connect to network Ralph and vanellope
picked the perfect time to go to the
Wi-Fi router as it just happens to be
the very moment lip wackest turning it
on and operating it also in the previous
movie mister lip wax first name is Stan
but on his nametag here it's clearly del
the hell happened there
let's Litwack arcade taken over by
Stan's evil twin through this very
strange arcane process vanellope and
Ralph are shot through the internet you
gotta get there somehow I suppose but
even for a warped cartoon reality this
seems like a stretch I know it seems
like they're going super fast from their
perspective but this is an aching Lee
slow pace for data to travel for that
reason I'll assume lit wax internet
provider is Devin Lee Comcast
you know a movie is in trouble when it
looks like the same world from the emoji
movie I know Ralph has to have a place
he can break but why does the internet
always have to be represented by some
central city in TV and movies isn't the
entire point that it's not centralized
they never say thank you does the knows
more search engine really not know how
this works if someone actually said
thank you to him that would be world
chattering it's very intuitive just say
bla bla bla movie the only reason
Penelope is better at internetting than
Ralph is is that she's playing a younger
character I mean it's not like she's an
actual spring chicken the whole reason
they're here is because her old ass
games been discontinued also can we
discuss how incredibly convenient it is
that back installed Wi-Fi in the arcade
on the exact day that sugar rush broke
oh isn't that cute twitter is being
presented here is a nice world full of
cute birds showing cat photos and not as
a full-on bloodbath bird bath bloodbath
of racism stupidity trolling stupidity
and race pity if Google is proudly in
this movie then why did they even need a
nose more yes we know where to go we
ever need a pair of goggles no seriously
this is the best this movie could offer
in this context I loved you wreck-it
Ralph you were the animated chosen one
well spider-man and his spider verse has
the high ground I'm trying very hard and
failing to figure out what all this foot
traffic wandering aimlessly at eBay
represents man just like pig and
elephant DNA premature celebration and
eBay definitely won't splice goddamn it
movie if you're gonna be a Chappelle
show skit ripoff at least show some
balls and throw in some pole the beaver
is a beautifully taxidermy beaver oh you
that doesn't count the tortilla chips
shaped like international superstar
Beyonce Knowles goes for 400 now I know
the movies trolling me since that ship
would have gone for way more in real
life not only is vanellope able to pick
out this one unites them in the middle
of all of this there just happens to be
someone bidding on it right now and the
auction is just about to run out
Joker's the vanellope and Ralph have no
idea how eBay works and they just think
that's saying the biggest number wins
not knowing its money and this auction
itself doesn't even put a dollar sign in
front of the current bit like it's
actively trying to prevent them from
figuring it out but they know about
money
tapper demanded it earlier for raus bar
tab and well never says the dollar
amount outloud he does balk at getting a
new one and says that's more than this
game makes in a year so contact clues
even for video game characters
should get them to figure this out we
are set to ship one sugar rush steering
wheel ooh a lip wax family fun land in
Los Alamitos California and we don't
need a real shipping address for that we
tell our nation's delivery workers to
just figure that out on their own I'll
just need a credit card number eBay
didn't even need the credit card before
they started bidding or before they gave
them an address to ship it probably
because they wanted to destroy vanellope
and Ralph's dreams after they thought
they wanted wended vanilla peas
glitching become tied to her anxiety I
thought it was supposed to be a goddamn
superpower not a nervous tic I got a guy
in Des Moines Iowa will pay 40 grand for
shanks car from a game called slaughter
race someone is actually willing to pay
40 grand for a video game car it's
amazing family doesn't get more business
if there are people willing to shell out
the amount of money it takes to get a
real car did they seriously just walk
here and are wandering through the game
unattended like how long have they been
walking where was the entrance to the
game itself what are the rules of the
travel in this movie look there it is
movie I'm giving up with listing how
many ways your absurdly convenient after
the discovery of this super rare car
within seconds of entering this game so
here's ten extra sins to cover what I'm
sure is a mountable for the rest of the
runtime hey I think that might be sick
Ralph is dumb sure and the movies making
a joke here about him stating the
obvious but is it suggesting that he
just saw the big title card splash on
the screen like we did Chris tells me
there's no way that this screen wouldn't
get cracked after being hit with a
controller because of the results
gathered from the wallet test
hey shank did you ever wonder what it
would be like if someone actually did
get your car movie is making it sound
like the community of players of this
world's most popular game couldn't
figure out how to get shanks car sharing
information on what happens when you go
inside the warehouse no way this whole
thing is staged makes it look like well
it might be difficult it's not a
difficult as the movie is saying it is
I'm here from the Department of noise
right after an unsuccessful attempt to
steal her car shrink entertains Ralph's
silly ruse long enough for vanellope to
try to steal it I thought her title card
said her favorite weapon was smart I'm
just I'm just a cop Baberaham Lincoln
who was a hardcore gamer and was on the
verge of stealing the most coveted item
in the world's most popular game
suddenly acts ridiculously timid just
because Schenk got in the car and why
she just started over it's not like she
has anything to lose by standing up the
shank
bull you get the horns the round the
Furious vanellope has the best car in
the game and shank does not at this
point it's just about speed and not
technique so how the hell did she catch
up to her so fast in some randos Hoopoe
so out of the entire net no one else is
playing this game right now or at least
in this location seems like a pretty
popular place but it's completely
abandoned for the scene Jesus how much
lucky is this shank not only knows what
she needs to do to get past the fire but
she apparently had all her other moves
mapped out beyond that even though she
couldn't see what the situation was on
the other side even in video game world
a car going in Reverse to catch up to
this car going forward is a sick hit big
boy with a blow and go love to wait
what's the I guarantee you this is not
what you'll find if you google blow and
go there are much better ways to make
money on the internet than stealing cars
if this thing goes viral honestly
between attempting to steal shanks car
and trying to get videos to go viral on
the internet for money which one is more
difficult I'm gonna say getting videos
to go viral also they need the money in
like 24 hours
try accumulating 27001 dollars in one
day on YouTube through sheer advertising
and no extortion everybody knows the
video sharing site hell they've already
literally shown the YouTube app when
they first got to the Internet so why
the didn't they just use that for the
sea storage also just so I'm unclear
these are NPCs in a singular video game
that are making self aware viral videos
for people in the real world by using
web connected phones that are part of
that game's digital environment do I
have that wrong here to let you know
your be expires in 8 hours when they try
to checkout from ebay the bots said that
they'd hold the item for 24 hours so
holy
it took them 16 hours to meet with
family and do the whole slaughter race
caper also what's happening back at the
arcade if it has taken this long
it's definitely open so how are they
explaining Ralph's absence if we nickel
and dime it with spanley it will take 20
years to make enough money to buy the
wheel it's hilarious that family has
videogame quests that can net 5 or 6
bucks or $40,000 and nothing between
those values that could add up over very
little time you are trending and these
are for you heart guards it's like if
Disney asked me specifically what I
didn't want this movie to be and then
made that exact movie your buddy account
converts hearts into dollars
meritocracies
what if I made you a whole bunch of
videos of me doing all kinds of crazy
things you
saturate the market that could get you a
lot of hearts fast pretty sure this is
not how it works but Kari Allen movie
this is already exhausting I'm just copy
whatever is popular yes yes was
literally just poopoo in the derivative
videos that maybe was showing her this
movie cannot get out of its own way can
it let's get to work
I'm sorry is the algorithm for the site
making content for the site I know we're
anthropomorphizing a lot in this movie
but this one scrambles my brain worse
than that PCP I took a few hours ago I
just threw my wallet and my ps4
controller at the screen the controller
and the screen broke and once I paid to
have the knee replace my wallet followed
suit messy you super random video check
it out dude
like the dupe behind you can't just see
this for himself on your screen every
single asshole in this office building
is watching a different round video and
while it serves your purpose for this
one shot it's implausible and wrong and
I hate it
okay I'll give you five seconds to
explain to me what this section of the
movie is is it a satire about the vapid
and banal videos that people will
mindlessly consume the commentary on the
ultimate futility of content creativity
and rumination on the ubiquity of viral
videos in the workplace I'm sorry your
time is up we're gonna go with dumb
montage that's a dumb montage we haven't
been a part in like six years you know
except for the majority of every day
when they go off to play their
respective games I'm being overly
literal here of course but the movie
makes it out to seem like they can't
spend any time apart and that's
definitely not true this really should
have been titled we own all the things
and wanted to remind you about that the
movie also you got a handle to them for
a sticking Dumbo in their city of Disney
porn I'm surprised neon letters aren't
embossed into his trunk saying coming in
March this the vanellope runs into the
Disney Princesses part of the movie is
the best part unfortunately it feels
like it's already been done by Shrek the
third not better find you just done I
literally want a steering wheel then why
are you sitting around with all these
delightful but unnecessary character
considering there's got to be very
little time before the item is released
also at this point they know at least
generally how eBay works so why wouldn't
they just let the 27001 dollar bid
expire and then go back in and bid on it
again with the revenue they have from
Ralph's videos is it so we can have an
artificial deadline for this movie I
think it's so we can have an artificial
deadline for this movie Wow movie is
saying that the algorithm for the site
within the internet lost the connection
to the Internet in which it's
this happens shouldn't the world outside
be falling apart this terrible Ralph
goat video has an ungodly 130 million
views in seven hours
for reference ariana grande's thank you
necks got fifty five point four million
views in 24 hours and Ralph's gouchin
anagen czar barely better than that song
so give me a fucking break Ralph spins
the display with the goat video at one
hundred and thirty million views and
when we return it's sitting at three
hundred and two million the idea of this
amount of views more than doubling in
three seconds is slim it's the comments
section Ralph and none of those internet
avatars are here despite the comments
being currently added vanellope sings a
place called slaughter race and I rolled
the fuck out of my eyes when the song
started but it's awesome everything that
this movie should have been smart
subversive pointed relevant I'm gonna
finally take a sin off or something it's
the Sequoia Speedway how did the Nile
pee get to slaughter a so quickly she
was all the way out in Disney town just
a few minutes ago right and isn't she's
supposed to be in yes his personal
browsing history I'm sick of trying to
figure out the rules in this movie
especially considering it's almost 75%
through can I tell you something that I
don't think I could ever tell Ralph he's
behind me isn't he I wanted to wait
until this very moment to say this how
dangerous is it really alone if you get
in a wreck do you feel pain and if you
do for how long can you even die so fair
way to do something like that's a
slaughter race he's talking about a
virus but let's review this sharing a
video game character from a 1980s arcade
hit somehow transported himself via
electrical cables into a router which
sent him to the Internet where he met
this pop-up add names family together
without any human interference
whatsoever they'll create a virus and
somehow mess up slaughter race that
innocent I don't know what is this dude
is a virus making machine Wow low pump
lives down here
thank you your system I mean oh sure all
the villains give away their super
dangerous and valuable malware
completely free especially in the dark
with hang on vanellope just straight
abandoned ralph with no explanation she
seriously doesn't think he'll notice
she's gone especially since she agreed
to meet him at ebay like two hours ago
I don't care she's stalling because he's
gonna be upset that's completely out of
character deliver the car to purge chop
shop but watch out for shank and her
crew considering the shank is generally
considered unbeatable because this movie
has told us she is does that mean no
one's gotten past this part of the game
either
I mean stealing her car is one thing but
getting through a normal everyday level
let's not forget this is a massively
popular game and that people would be
wondering how the hell the obscure
character from sugar rush got here
without the programmers doing anything
in security distributing insecurity the
most harmful aspect of this virus is its
need to vocalize everything it does will
be fine but your code isn't part of this
game we got to get you out of here now
this would be a hazard even if there
wasn't a virus attacking insecurities in
the game a server reboot often does that
happen during an online games life like
a lot right luckily for vanilla Peas
chances of survival the virus progresses
through the game right behind her kind
of like the Deep Freeze in The Day After
Tomorrow when you can predict that a
protagonist fight before the climax of
the movie cliches gonna happen before
you even watch the movie you shouldn't
have that cliche in your movie the virus
was still in the game when slaughter
race rebooted right so why is it allowed
to continue virus along after the fact
raus heavy hands uncover heavy-handed
symbolism breaking news the internet is
under assault how did that giant TV with
full volume come from certainly hasn't
been on during this whole movie 28,000
Ralphs later world war are followed them
you mean you weren't in the lead because
how the fuck did you get past a million
Ralph's to get inside here sort of a
codependent Pied Piper situation we know
a Pied Piper yeah the Ralph's are drawn
to vanellope so why did they need yes to
be the Pied Piper can't they get into
any vehicle and as long as the vanellope
is in it they can lead the rouse to the
antivirus chamber yes I forgot to tell
Ralph at when you break the internet you
don't literally have to break the
internet role Ralphie's I mean dude
obviously made some real questionable
choices here but he also made a beep pun
to save his best friend's game so what
can I say a kid life's complicated this
is the worst part of this movie by far
because the story means to balance
Ralph's catastrophic actions
yes brings up the fact that he did
something really embarrassing and stupid
to save vanellope 'he's game but he
doesn't get to about the game all he
cares about is vanellope being around
possessing her so to speak it's what all
his dialogue and actions have revealed
about his character I never said I
didn't want to be your
they said you were acting like a bad
friend oh really then what was this
scene then you threw the heart necklace
away you told him you were going in
wherever he wasn't told him not to
follow you and told him to leave you
alone I admit there wasn't a I don't
want to be your friend in there but it's
a far cry from what you're saying it was
and you were right to feel that way Oh
premature celebration aside how the do a
bunch of giant Ralph's catch up to this
speeding vehicle all the individual
Ralph's combined to form one giant
insecure Ralph because that makes total
sense that means beyond their
destructive feelings for vanellope they
also have creepy vault Roenick desires
King Ralph is distracted by real Ralph
despite its singular vanellope focus
what the stakes here is the internet
really in danger especially since the
wrath of Ralph's is solely focused on
pursuing vanellope can ralph really be
killed by King Ralph well any of this
matter by the time the inevitable third
entry titled wreck-it is introduced so
was the rest of the Internet cool it was
previously overrun with all the routes
but now that they've coalesced into one
giant figure I guess all the shit's back
online and the virus that's loose in the
entire Internet didn't find any other
insecurities to duplicate in the entire
Internet oh I just realized something
these Ralph's are essentially one
gigantic human centipede just gotta
trust her cuz that's what best friends
do I'd like everyone to remember that
this is a 100% insecure embodiment of
Ralph's codependency and somehow it was
able to be reasoned with okay it's a big
strong man in need of rescuing princess
machina
yeah okay this Disney Princesses rescued
the day montage she's pretty funny and
sometimes clever but movie has spent any
goodwill it had left on that giant
roffels also this is an absurdly
complicated plan to save one falling
dude like just send the carpet to catch
him or have the ice slide reach all the
way to the ground
or million other things that would work
more easily you know she ain't a did
they call it an if he thinks the
programmers of slaughter race must be
damn proud of themselves to create a
goddamn sentient video game character
that can change programming code if
anyone investigates this they found news
equaling the discovery of alien life
this wave seen last 25 seconds but I
assure you and outlast the ending of The
Return of the King even though we got
that steering wheel and save sugar rush
that's never really gonna be the same um
yeah the most popular character in the
game has mysteriously left it and nobody
noticed this how on earth did you tame
those things clearly it's granny law
Jesus does Jane Lynch have to do this in
every movie the bunny gets cake no line
this is terrifying this is supposed to
be an amusing credit scene and the bunny
goddamn pops the worst Marvel ever did
was made people aware schwarmann exists
you want me to give you the number of a
different cable company that can all
wait we're it aren't we like doesn't the
very nature of our existence make you
wonder if there's more to life than this
you've gotta keep living man Li VI in
that kid
sweet I will take a break and she'll
quit the drugs yeah do it oh I've been
praying about this day for so long what
did you just put in your mouth
[Music]
let me just say that if God was a city
planner he would not put a playground
next to a sewage system
well you meet you nice to meet you mo
don't say mo the Internet can also be a
place where you find a steering wheel at
one website or play Mortal Kombat with
your friends get dumb
[Applause]